journalism is under attack
like never before well no perspective
you have to have the fact
beautiful but tragic because people are
doubting everything
you're the only way of telling their
story how would you describe this
outbreak something like an apocalypse
you're going to be
really tired you're going to be really
scared it's too dangerous
anyone who says they're not scared is
life anything
can happen did you get here i sometimes
wonder how have we managed to get out of
this we do
genuinely believe in what we do he's
clearly marching press
to show the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover
an injustice this is the result of
ethnic cleansing
i don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford
i'm stuart ramsey and this is hot spots
[Music]
coming up on hotspots
we gain rare access to north yemen and
witness a country
torn apart by war nine of them dead
hunger and now coronavirus there was a
really high number
of health workers who had died
and i'm in chihuahua state in mexico
where our people-smuggling story takes
an unexpected
turn these are women
and they deal with children we did not
see them cross
it just all felt wrong
they targeted this house that used to
contain three families
80 of the population of yemen cannot
survive
without help
yemen is basically divided into two
it's got the houthi rebels in charge in
the north
they are backed by iran
and then in the south you've got the
internationally recognised government
supported by a coalition of countries
spearheaded by saudi arabia and backed
by britain america and united arab
emirates
all of these outside countries are
funding
this very long protracted and bloody war
[Music]
not only is it the world's worst
humanitarian disaster but it was also
now being hit by a global pandemic
this was one country which was already
on its knees
and what does it mean to millions and
millions of people who are caught in
this crisis
we spent probably two years trying to
get visas and access to get back into
yemen
which is a very complicated procedure
ahmed baider is basically mr yemen
yesterday the front line was very hot
and it's very dangerous for them snipers
so they they said we have to talk to
like the biggest high commander
and he's done almost the impossible
which is
be a yemeni and straddle both sides of
the conflict
ahmed bader said to us welcome to yemen
this is the land
before coronavirus it's like it had
never happened
have you had many people coming asking
for medicines for
coronavirus do you think many people
have got ill
and died from it here in yemen
why do you think there's no corona in
yemen
there was a really high number of health
workers who had died which suggested
that
the coronavirus deaths as a whole were
way off the scale
[Music]
against corona how do you describe cuts
it's an upper that's what the kids would
call it this is good anti-coronavirus
and the secret behind it is you keep on
sort of slowly adding these cut leaves
into the side of your mouth and you end
up growing this massive bulge
that guy literally can't speak he's got
so much cat in his mouth
it just looks bizarre just with lump
hair and just having a normal
conversation just his big lump just
[Applause]
our minder is laughing at me because i
keep on putting on the hand sanitizer it
says you keep putting it on
all the time all the time another one
who doesn't believe in coronavirus
we went to the main coronavares hospital
in sana
what the doctors were saying there was
very different to what the
houthi authorities were telling their
people
which was that coronavirus wasn't really
an
issue or a problem can you hear me
there was a really high number of health
workers who had died
that was very worrying because the
medical infrastructure is so fragile
anyway
we are in an emergency situation already
it's tough we hope we hope to
another organization to help us we hope
to
send the message for the world to stop
the war stop the conflict
and help the yemeni to negotiation and
peace
is definitely rampant and much worse
than
what the authorities are saying but it's
not nearly as bad as all the other
problems that yemenis are having to cope
with
i have no idea how many hours we
actually spent
traversing that country
as it went on hour after hour
after hour muhammad ali
houthi is one of the most senior
figures in the houthi movement it's very
rare to be given
access outside of his office
[Music]
what are you singing do you want to
listen is it in the key
oh funny
somehow these 4x4 vehicles would be
gingerly going up and down all the huge
boulders and
round hairpin bends
i don't even know how you do it on foot
this is what the north yemenis have to
put up with
really poor infrastructure anyway and
what little they have
has been bombed
so here you have muhammad ali houthi one
of the most
influential people in the
houthi-controlled part of the country
essentially trying to broker a peace
deal between two warring
factions but warring factions within
his territory and which gives you an
idea of just how
complicated and just how fractured yemen
is
what was most notable was one
almost everyone had a gun or a weapon
and two how united they were in their
condemnation and hatred of the west in
america
whatever quarrels they had amongst each
other the big
enemy and the enemies were those that
were
part of the the coalition that was
making the north
yemenis suffer so much excuse me sir do
you think these people are united
against the coalition
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
we'd heard of this attack an
air strike in a very remote mountainous
area near the saudi border
and we set out to investigate it
was incredibly difficult
[Music]
finally here's how these people live up
here
there's no electricity no running water
and they've been bombed no outsider had
been there before
we got there
the last
so
um
all of them women and children i
foreign
there were the remnants of people's
lives there
all around here as far as you can see
there is just
mountains farms small communities
very difficult to see what could be
conceived of as a legitimate
military target here
do you get depressed seeing things like
that over and over again
it was very very difficult but the most
important thing is we send the story to
people all around the world they have to
know how people are suffering
it's one of the most difficult trips
that i have done
but i really think it's worth it even
all of the barriers
and how it's very hard and you can see
now how it's very difficult
thank you so much well done my drivers
are the best always
[Music]
they pulled out three survivors
[Music]
salaam alaikum alike we first went to
the young woman's house she was the
matriarch of the house just
a young woman she had
two children who died in that
foreign
[Music]
he was a young boy this 14 year old or
something like that
okay i was in a coma
for five days his physical scars
had more or less healed but he was still
obviously so
emotionally traumatized
i was very shocked when they told me
that
most of my family have been killed
we got our stories out uh
whilst we were in yemen and we got alex
in fact got a
an email from a senior un
lawyer who is investigating accusations
of
of warcraft alleged war crimes
there was a massacre that day and
someone
should be held accountable for that
it's very hard to exaggerate just how
bad
the humanitarian crisis is in yemen
most explicitly uh is
showing you you know the story of one
clinic
in one province of northern yemen
that was the introduction you know this
is the real
this is the real side of it now you know
[Music]
these are mothers who are cradling their
children as they
gasp for breath
every single child
was in a terrible state
most of them were there because
they didn't have enough to eat
you know here in 2020
there are children dying
lots of them dying
[Music]
because they don't have enough to eat
for me the pictures are bad enough but
it was just
the sound of crying children and it was
[Music]
constantly
[Music]
goodness me doesn't look well at all
it was a desperate desperate sight
[Music]
there didn't seem to be enough medics
to cope with these continual mounting
never-ending challenges of just trying
to fight to save
baby child toddler
and then we noticed
they brought in an oxygen tank next to
one of the beds
there was this tiny tiny little scrap of
a thing
with tiny little hands and fingers
and they had this device that was
monitoring the heartbeat
and this baby was really struggling
very much
[Music]
did i like
yes
yeah she died in that little bed and i
i just uh know running up a bit now but
it just started crying and then i
you know i had to stop because you know
i was absolutely
crying my eyes out literally cropping my
eyes out
i just couldn't see my hand letting the
lens you know
i just had to stop what i was doing
[Music]
and the mothers just sort of melted away
and went back to their
their own children
is the preventable it's not like
inevitable that it's
something that we can't prevent by only
giving
food or
little things are just you know how
simple is that
if they just had some food
these are the kinds of stories that you
find across the country
it's not in one specific place it's not
on one specific side
it's children who are starving to death
it's children who were being maimed who
were being shot
who were being killed in some cases
being recruited as soldiers to fight
it was just frustration i think was that
the overwhelming takeaway that
i had it was just an absolute
frustration that this has been going on
for years
it seems like there's no end in sight
frankly
it doesn't matter how much all these
other countries try and absolve
themselves of responsibility
they are all responsible for
perpetuating this war
because right now yemen's just in the
middle of
a war that's not even in their control
yemenis were so excited uh
to see westerners back in the country
thank you you know i think the tourists
back or the westerners back in the
country
i want to tell you that you are the best
people
and there wasn't a single restaurant
that we went to that weren't
so generous and and
kind and helpful and accommodating when
we'd come in
hi girls
i think yemen is very much the forgotten
war
in many ways because it's so hard
for independent journalists to get in
it's not given
much recognition
it's a stunning country which really
doesn't deserve
to to live under this shadow of
of death and war all the time
[Music]
it's really difficult to get in and once
you're in you have to really make every
second every minute every hour count
the guy in charge is basically like out
of a tarantino movie
he was somebody you didn't want to get
on the wrong side of
i thought that something doesn't feel
quite right here
we had another story and it's just
literally around the corner
it's one of the things i love about this
job it's a constant adventure
here was a story about one of our most
precious natural resources water
you thought we were doing one story we
ended up doing a completely different
one
[Music]
mexico is a fantastic place to work
it's quite fun the people are really
nice and then you have these
undertones of really real nasty stuff as
well so it's perfect it's great stories
and it's next door to the united states
with this what nearly 2 000 mile long
border
its position as the country of transit
for huge amounts of drugs to the united
states
is very interesting and challenging as a
journalist
[Music]
mexico is a really cool country
cities are cool the scenery's cool and
the people are cool
and there's just loads of really
fascinating stories
it's edgy as well you can find yourself
in a dangerous situation pretty easily
it's kind of the gift that keeps on
giving as far as storytelling goes
[Music]
this is where somebody's been killed
right it's a place that seems to be a
constant source of stories for us
we've been with gangs making crystal
meth
we have joined the police and we've
joined drug cartels
in acapulco we've been to opium fields
that you could never get to unless you
knew they were there
and we've been with people being
trafficked across
the border to the united states you're
often dealing with inherently dodgy
people
you have to be thinking constantly about
your own security
you have to be thinking about if they're
telling you the truth yeah well here we
are in uh
chihuahua i'm not absolutely certain
what we're up to once again trying to be
with crime gangs and you never know if
they're gonna be on time or not
we had heard about the smuggling ring in
juarez that
actually specializes in children
unaccompanied minors
during covert 19 the trump
administration deported
many children back to mexico and many
were trying to get back to their parents
to their families inside the u.s so
there was this whole
market for lack of a better word in
smuggling children
juarez is one of the most infamous
border towns
in mexico it's completely controlled by
the cartels
it has incredible levels of movement of
migrant people
it has a drug trade it has
so much danger that few years ago you
would regularly see bodies
hanging from motorway bridges so a
really really dangerous place
always
staying alert is the name of the game
when you're working in
a place like juarez
police are going around in pickup trucks
but with heavy machine guns
very heavily armed themselves so you're
aware that
trouble could come your way very easily
good reason it's known as one of the
nastiest places on earth
yeah you can't just
idly wander around and say oh that's a
nice picture let me take a picture of
that you actually got to think what are
you doing how long am i going to be here
for and then let's get it done
get in the car and keep moving
ulysses has worked with us for a very
long time now he's our main guy he gets
things done he
understands what we need he's the guy
who will reach out to various contacts
to make
stories happen ulysses introduced us
to a journalist friend of his who had
good contacts
with a cartel controlled gang who
smuggled
drugs but also people well we're off to
meet
um a house with uh coyotes and okay
these are people who
take would-be migrants to the united
states across the border
we've met loads of them over the years
um what's
uh intriguing about this is that these
are women
and they they deal with children
[Music]
so we went to film at the location
where they keep the children
and families in the days before they're
waiting to cross
and there there were two children a
brother and a sister and
there was a woman with her daughter and
they all wanted to go to america
we met a woman who was the coyote who
was going to be
their guide some people would say that
you shouldn't be doing this because the
job to the authorities the children
should go legally and it shouldn't
happen what do you say
to those people
she is a gang member and she is being
paid to do it
but she seemed to have a genuine belief
that she was doing the right thing for
these children
[Music]
they have no real moral issue about what
they're doing with children because
actually they're doing humanitarian work
because they're reuniting them with
their parents
okay and then we met the ringleader
who runs this network okay he pulled out
you know kilo of cocaine
friendly to us but he was somebody you
didn't want to get on the wrong side of
the process of getting over how is it
done are women less stopped
the guy in charge is basically like out
of a tarantino movie i mean you couldn't
have made it up
he was an interesting character i had no
reason to doubt that he is indeed
a gangster in charge of the coyotes that
move the kids
and certainly has some part to play in
the movement of people
and drugs for the cartels people like
him are not unusual in a place like
mexico and certainly not in juarez
it's there yeah
i don't know what it was but from the
moment that i stepped in that
flat i thought that something doesn't
feel
quite right here because everything is
going to plan
and it never goes to plan
this was just going too smoothly
having done so much work with gangsters
i mean nothing ever happens on time
you usually spend days waiting and then
it's on then it's off
on off on this one just went according
to plan
at that point i didn't say right guys we
need to leave this is nonsense i thought
okay there's no harm in keeping filming
giving the story the benefit of the
doubt and seeing how it all plays out
we were then invited to join them as
they moved up towards the border with
the united states
there was this lady and her young
daughter that were going to be smuggled
across
but why would you be doing the crossing
in the middle of the day it just doesn't
really make sense
[Music]
if they don't want to be seen surely
you'd go at night
for me the absolute main box tick if i
can put it that way to verify
the story was going to be actually
seeing
these migrants cross the border like
actually seeing it with our own eyes
they're crossing over the rio grande
which is once upon a time a very
major river it's now pretty much a sort
of dry
canal to all intense purposes and on the
other side they're going to be
picked up by people who are waiting for
them
initially we thought that i might break
away from the rest of the team and go
up to the border to witness the crossing
but that suddenly got the kibosh and
then it was that we couldn't drive to a
place where we could actually oversee
the border
we had to stay back and it became
apparent that
they didn't want us to see the crossing
and again alarm bells ringing
we did not see them cross into the
united states
it just all felt wrong at that point
we didn't see them crossing that left me
feeling very uncomfortable because
although there were elements of the
story that i believe were absolutely
true and that
the characters as individuals were true
i just wondered whether
the scenario that we had just filmed
was actually a real scenario
and as it turned out actually all of us
individually
including our fixers were kind of
struggling a bit with it and thinking
something's not quite right here and
that's when as a team we actually sat
down and had a conversation about it
[Music]
you do not want to ring your boss and
say i'm really sorry but
we've come all this way to do a story
that didn't stand up
but if it's not on we're not running the
story that that's something you have to
do
we go to great pains to make sure the
stories we tell are accurate
even more so now in an environment where
the fake news label is thrown around so
readily
you cannot risk having any mistakes
whatsoever
even if they're genuine mistakes because
people
who want to discredit you will pick up
on those
and use that to call the whole thing
fake news
we really didn't know whether the end of
our story
was legit or not so we decided to give
them an opportunity show us pictures
from inside the united states
and we can go with the story no pictures
no story
that never materialized and so we had to
make the decision to bin the story
ulysses rang the coyote said
what happened there and she said listen
it was all real it's just
he overdid it in the end the elements
were all real
it just it didn't happen when we were
there
you have to be correct every single time
there cannot be any holes in the stories
you're doing
i didn't feel we failed in fact it's
probably a success because
failure would have been reporting
something that wasn't true
when we made the decision not to file
that story i felt
a wave of relief i actually slept well
that night and i know for sure that if
we pursued and carried on with that
story i wouldn't have slept
at all that
[Music]
you're night you've spent a lot of time
working on this story
but you have to accept it didn't work
out and you move on of course the
amazing thing about our job
perhaps amazing thing about mexico is
it's actually another story and it's
just literally around the corner
and we had one more that we've been
looking at for a while
which is about a dispute between local
farmers
and the mexican government over water
chihuahua is a huge state and a very dry
one
it would be a desert but it has huge
rivers
that flow through it and those rivers
then go into reservoirs and from the
reservoirs
they can basically feed the earth and
grow and as a result it's sort of
agricultural
center for mexico and it's full of
farmers
producing a whole range of vegetables
and livestock
it is a massive production area and
that's all to do with irrigation
one of my concerns going to do this
story was that it was almost too local
for international viewers to grasp it
but what really struck me was that here
was a story
about the future of one of our most
precious natural resources water
mexico and united states have a 70 year
old agreement for sharing water on one
side of the country mexico sent it to
the united states and on the other side
of the country united states sends it to
mexico
mexico messed up its water supply
agreement to the united states and
decided they needed water
from reservoirs reservoirs belong to the
farmers
who need the water to grow the crops
which ironically
are then sold to the united states 100
of them that was the basis of this story
international agreement between two big
countries and a small group of farmers
stuck in the middle saying you're not
having our water
the farmers they had taken over the dam
from the authorities were not going to
budge it was their water as far as they
were concerned and
it was gonna stay that way
what we found was a real eye-opener
because
we met educated successful
non-violent non-aggressive big
farmers prepared to actually fight
physically fight the national guard to
save their water as remarkable
[Music]
was a welcome contrast to what we had
experienced
in juarez there was a kind of a party
atmosphere going on
with food and music and stuff it didn't
feel dangerous
these people are decent hard-working
law-abiding
farming folk and they were really
pleased to see us
really nice people amazed that a bunch
of foreigners arrived there
and they were very gracious and very
courteous to us the whole time
it's like you've come from britain it's
like yeah we've come from britain to do
this story
i think that actual complete and utter
shock that anyone cared but you know
nobody was drinking they was clearly
taking this very seriously
there were younger guys who are going
out to do perimeter security
around the local area we want to take a
walk
we had not planned for jorge to be the
main character in our story
but there was something about him that
was incredibly warm and genuine
so jorge just kind of very naturally and
organically became our character
jessica yeah yeah the conflict between
the farmers and the government it had
been quite violent
what had made matters much worse is that
soldiers had shot dead one of the local
farmers a young woman named jessica who
was very involved and very well loved by
the community
and this really escalated the situation
and more and more farmers started
joining
the ranks of those who had held onto
this reservoir promising not to give it
up
the dam's huge very impressive several
hundred meters
up which isn't the best situation
for stuart to be conducting an interview
my problem is i have terrible vertigo
and i'm really afraid of heights
it is a long way down yeah it's very
high
i'm generally okay with with heights and
i was moving around to try and get some
shots and there was a substantial
uh railing running along it all seemed
perfectly solid to me and i needed to
get back a bit and i lent against this
section of railing
boom suddenly it just went and i i
almost went
back over the over the thing and i saw
look around and
she's going ah hey richie i thought i'd
lost you then
i won't deny my ass went a little bit
then
people tried to blow us up and shoot us
and god knows what
to go that way would it it would have
been a bit of an anti-climax i think
really
i'm just thinking let's just get this
over with as soon as possible so jorge
and i agreed that we would go up to the
top bit of the dam
got up there and it is staggeringly
beautiful
you look across the water for miles and
then the sun
hitting the hills and then you look out
across the valley
and it's just green farmland all of it
dependent on one thing
the world's most important probably and
that is water
all the farmers you can see back down
there
20 000 families it depends from this
water
that is then what made the story that
much more important we weren't just
talking about
small farmers we're talking about an
entire industry
that was potentially going to be on its
knees because they weren't getting
access to water
those valleys those farms don't exist
without the water
we knew that there was another dam that
the national guard soldiers were holding
and protecting so we drive down
a fairly innocuous looking road past all
the farmland
turn the corner and sort of look round
and there are soldiers absolutely
everywhere
they're in defensive positions
roadblocks
lots of them all in full combat gear
they were prepared for violence
the soldiers themselves were really
heavily armed
both with military weapons but they also
had
riot gear yeah it was a real eye-opener
it was kind of surreal to see that many
soldiers
standing protecting water at a dam i
think at least visually in that moment i
thought
okay so we've been calling this story
water wars
wow it really does sort of look a bit
like a wall
what we wanted to do was to walk through
their checkpoints and go up and see the
dam
the army were having absolutely none of
it so we just said we'll have to find
another way around
so jorge said to us if you want to see
the water from that dam
there's not much of it left but i can
take you around the
back roads
farmers know how to get across their
land and so they knew exactly how to get
around the
army and take us to what was a huge
reservoir
except there was virtually no water left
it went off a mile after mile after mile
of basically
sort of like a like a beach
the scene that greeted us it reminded me
of a moonscape
clearly it had been very heavily drained
there were like huge beaches which had
obviously been
underwater very recently
it was really strange i'm not sure i've
actually seen terrain like that before
well the farmers tell me that this dam
and the reservoir has been drained
as part of the payment of mexico's
national water debt to the united states
in march this was full
suffice to say in march i'd have been at
least
11 meters underwater
we should have been 11 meters underwater
but it had gone
and that is what they didn't want to
happen to the farmers dam which was
still full
this one had been let out to pay its
debt to the united states
of course remembering the deal isn't bad
for mexico it's good
the point is from chihuahua state
it's bad
[Music]
water wars has been predicted as a
likely issue
for decades that story
is just a microcosm of what is likely to
become stories
that affect countries all over the world
this is just a tiny version of it
but conflict will happen because of the
lack of water as
the earth gets warmer and warmer and
there's absolutely no doubt about that
it's one of the things i love about this
job it's a constant adventure and you
genuinely do not know when you set out
on the road what you're going to find
at the end of that journey we went off
to do what we thought would be another
crime story we decided it just didn't
stand up and we made the right call and
we're all happy that we made that
and then we moved on to another story
which was
you know could have almost been seen as
a backup but just goes to show that you
just don't know what you're going to get
and turned out to be a little gem
it's always rewarding and it happens
very rarely but it is always rewarding
to do a story that you feel
has actually had an impact and if that's
even just on one person's life then it's
been worth your while it doesn't have to
be a story that changes the world
within 24 hours the mexican and united
states governments reached an agreement
they decided to delay the water release
and that there would be another
arrangement made
i genuinely believe that happened as a
direct result
of our story it was pretty special
[Music]
desperado
why don't you come to your senses
you've been out riding fences
for so long now
it may be raining
but there's a rainbow above
you better let somebody love you